the green ribbons of this long
campaign for justice may be fading
but this mother is clear about where she
wants to go
next she's bringing a civil claim for
damages against the american woman
accused of causing her son's death
it may well be the only justice we get
but it's
it's not the only justice that we want
we obviously want her to face the
criminal justice system as well and that
is still
our number one without a doubt is still
our number one
teenager harry dunn was killed in a
collision with
former cia agent anserkulas in august
2019.
it happened outside the american
intelligence base
raf croton in northamptonshire
she left the uk claiming diplomatic
immunity
but was later charged with causing death
by dangerous driving
the trump administration has refused to
extradite her
now the foreign secretary dominic raab
has written to harry's parents
he said i strongly support your right to
bring
this case as you know we have offered
support to allow you to attend the
hearings in virginia
and i understand other witnesses are
also ready to go to the u s
we've had mr rob and
his aides tell us for a year or so now
that
they are on our side that they're
supporting us that they're
they're doing everything that they can
but this
letter is the first piece of written
evidence that we've seen
that actually backs up that claim
not only is mrs sakulas refusing to
return to the uk to face
trial her legal team is disputing that
harry's family can take action in
virginia
mrs sakulasa's home state
without an extradition the family only
have a limited number of legal options
it's obviously very unusual for the
foreign secretary to
back an individual bringing a claim
in a foreign country but dominic raab
clearly thinks the united states
should have waived and secured his
immunity given that they didn't
the family have no choice as far as they
can see it
but to take a civil claim in the united
states against her
harry's family will find out in january
if the case can go ahead
in america lisa dowd sky news
northamptonshire